girl I'm so happy to see you it's good
to see you too it's just great to be on
your show well if it if it what for you
we might not have a show now come on
um it's so true true I have diarrhea
really bad and
um
this
This Woman's getting really really
comfortable
anyway I should probably get up
go up in the audience she's really hot
yeah she is is that your husband yes
not for long
I don't like that guy
single you know
[Applause]
why don't you kiss him right now
who wants to see
that
[Applause]
can I be honest with you no you know I
would have gone for the cheek because
hose before bros if you know what I mean
I don't wanna I don't want to make this
awkward but before the show Drew said to
me I want to make out with that guy
his wife
um you I called you and I we were trying
to you call it a pilot but really it's
like a sales tape or and and also let's
not forget audition in many ways and you
and I did a rocky sketch where you're my
coach getting me ready to host the show
but you're like uber passive and look
there you are in my head and I'm running
up the steps and and you did that with
me and I asked you a favor would you
come help me pull something off so maybe
I could prove I could do this you made
everybody laugh the most welcome
and
um you know I want people to know the
only reason I did that is it was
explained to me that um you were dying
right
it was a Make-a-Wish thing I am the
biggest nerd fan of all of your stand-up
and books and I would love to know how
do you look at life through a different
lens so that you can see it in a funnier
way it's all anger
it's anger but that's not palatable to
people and instead of murdering people
you do jokes
that makes sense a little bit I feel
like I'm your therapist right now I this
show is therapy this is so here's the
thing having kids which by the way is
horrible and you
biggest mistake of my life
but like with kids and we and um so
we're watching the Super Bowl Rihanna
and my 13 year old daughter she goes oh
Rihanna she's kind of for like old
people
and I was like you're talking about
Rihanna my second future wife
is for old people isn't that insane
there are children today that don't even
know what ZZ Top is
and a lot of people here too
no it's hard parenting is hard every
parent in this room regrets it
I'm saying look at that woman she's like
yeah
does your wife is she just so happy that
she gets to laugh like this all the time
because man if you can't my wife
despises me no it's
no I'm very lucky my wife is a hero I
mean she five kids is a lot she works so
hard and I try to travel as much as I
can
[Music]